What the Big Theta allows us to do is basically write complicated functions
in a much simpler way.
We can take a function like ½n² and just think of it as Θ(n²).
And 8√n we can think of a just Θ(√n).
Our equation from before, 2n - 2√n just becomes Θ(n).
It's just a linear function asymptotically.
A complicated expression like this where we have n⁴, which is the term that grows the fastest,
becomes Θ(n).
The ln n--in fact, any base log n is Big Theta of any other base log n as long as it's a constant.
I like to think in terms of base 2 logs, because I'm a computer scientist.
That's what we do.
π² is something that doesn't grow with n, and it ends up being in the set Θ(1).
It's just another constant.
Just to beat this dead horse a little bit longer, let's use the definition of Big Theta
to show that this expression that we determine for the growth in edges in a grid--
2n - 2√n--really is just a linear function. It grows like Θ(n).
The game plan is that we need to find constant c₁ and c₂--bigger than 0
and a threshold N₀ so that for all the n bigger than n₀, the function that we care about
is sandwiched between these two scalings.
Let's focus on this one first.
What c₂ can we plug in here so that we're guaranteed that this will be above this expression.
If we just copy this inequality down just flipping it around to make it a little easier to think about,
we want c₂ so that c₂n is bigger than this. Divide through by n
Now we need a c₂ that is bigger than 2 minus something that's actually growing.
Two should work for that.
If we set c₂ to 2, it will satisfy this inequality.
Let's just summarize all that
We can set c₂ = 2. What about c₁?
Well, let's take c₁ to be 1.
Intuitively, the idea being this function is growing like 2n minus something smaller than that.
So, n should be underneath that.
But let's just make show if c₁ is equal to 1, then we need n to be less than or equal
to this expression. For what values of n is that going to be true?
It's not true of all of them, but it's true for some of them.
We can add 2√n to both sides, subtract n from both sides, and we get that.
If we divide through by √n, we get 2 ≤ n/√n and divided by √n is actually √n.
So, we have 2 ≤ √n.
We square both sides. We have 4 ≤ n, or--flipping that around the other way--
if n ≥ 4, then this is true
That means we have to throw away the smaller values of n,
and we can do that very simply by setting n₀ to 4.
This only has to hold for n that are bigger than n₀.
That's what we've got there.
There we have it.
If we set the constants this way, n₀, c₁, and c₂, then what we find is
that for big enough n this more complicated expression is sandwiched between
two simple linear functions or to say it another way--